josée legault christian dufour michel
sur orge et bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
un mot sur paul st pierre plamondon qui
a été élu donc vendre une soir nouveau
chef du parti québécois josé vos
impressions oui alors seulement écouter
c'est sûr que monsieur passé pierre
plamondon
il ya énormément d'attentes devant lui
ça va être extrêmement difficile je
redirai parce que tous mes collègues ont
dit dans tous les médias depuis deux
jours en effet tout le monde avait sa
liste sur ce qu'ils devraient faire
donc on verra ce qu'il va faire là où je
pense il va avoir le plus grand défi ça
va être de garder son cap sur la
souveraineté
jusqu'à l'élection de 2022 parce que
vous savez que depuis le dernier
référendum
ça a été un énorme problème au parti
québécois doux au japon son déclin c'est
que dans l'opposition très souverainiste
et à mesure que l'élection approche au
dollar or là on commence à regarder les
sondages
on commence à s'inquiéter et là hop on
recule on recule on recule on recule
donc on va voir s'il va être capable de
tenir de 15 mg et chassé du si
l'élection faut qu'il fasse voir aussi
il sera pas élu sera pas l'assemblée
nationale les points de presse ne sera
pas évident il faut qu'il joue qu'il
faut qu'il existe d'abord oui c'est
l'expression de monsieur parizeau était
à l'assemblée nationale puis un jour il
y avait personne à 51 ans d'arrêt il ya
aussi monsieur c'est viable abandon
n'est pas dans une situation où il va
avoir une très grande visibilité
il doit faire en même temps le travail
de re de changer un peu le
message du parti québécois de moderniser
et en même temps de rebâtir un parti il
y avait 5000 personnes seulement qui ont
voté au leadership du parti québécois
c'est deux fois moins que la fois
d'avant puisse la partie qui a déjà eu
quatre cent mille membres
alors si c'est un travail ça
d'organisation d'aller voir les
présidents de comtés en abitibi puis
malheureusement c'est toujours quand et
en abitibi aller voir les présidents de
comtés qui se passe une crise à québec
pictures et agira pas à la crise alors
ça ça va être difficile pour lui
difficile pour les parlementaires
n'oublions pas que pour un seul député
qui appuient monsieur citya bleus mandon
et c'est vraiment un travail titanesque
d'un christian pas bravo tout d'abord
c'est vrai qu'il fait preuve de
persévérance il faut laisser la chance
au coureur
mais c'est vrai que les attentes sont
importantes même sens que ses défis ça
va être en fait de démontrer que il ya
ce qu'on appelle en anglais le killer
instinct qu un stand soir dont les
leaders politiques importants absolument
besoin pour réussir
c'est bien beau il est jeune il a l'air
gentil mais il reste que on peut dire
aussi des jeunes aux îles et jeudi jean
tiers et la politique des prochains
débats d'idées est un comble si le pq
est il menacé
un de ces grands adversaires c'est
québec solidaire se dit j'ai bien aimé
moi la façon dont il tient tête aux
pieds du racisme systémique ou i7 quoi
la bien pensante bien pensants on y
arrive à l'ami et bassins est ce que je
vais laisser la chance au coureur mais
choisir que ce bon hockey reims et cissé
mais justement je fais entendre monsieur
trudeau et monsieur legault qui l'a
expliqué peut-être plus simplement que
jamais son son refus d'utiliser ce terme
là on est content et on revient je peux
pas parler pour d'autres ministres ou
d'autres paliers du gouvernement
le gouvernement fédéral une savons
depuis longtemps que de reconnaître le
racisme systémique
c'est la première étape nécessaire pour
marcher sur cette voie de réconciliation
d'éliminer ces barrières réel et cette
violence qui est trop souvent fait
contre
peuples autochtones à travers le pays et
y conte et aussi d'autres un mineur
étaient visibles
ce taux devrait savoir qu'au québec il
ya deux gros et un groupe de québécois
qui disent oui il ya un système de
réussissent bien un groupe de québécois
qui disent non il n'y a pas de système
de racisme au québec
par conte comme à tous les québécois
disent il y aurait six au québec
actuellement ça serait pas une bonne
idée d'aller se met à dos une bonne
partie des québécois qui pense qui a pas
de système de racisme au québec comme le
propos ne se trouve pas ça serait une
erreur bon mais christian comme vous
avez commencé je vais je continuer avec
vous la tude vous vous êtes vous
partager cette analyse
moi j'espère vraiment que françois
legault se drogue pas la pression qui
devient énorme sexy creusement du
harcèlement mais ma position là dessus
et étrangers au canada il y aura du
racisme systémique à l'égard des
autochtones ça me semble évident les
autochtones au canada 100 la place
qu'ont les noirs aux états unis mais en
ce qui a trait aux autres minorités
visibles je trouve que de parler de
raciste systémique au québec chaussée
diderot charriage et je trouve que le
goût dopants à embarquer là dedans
malgré la bien pensante infinie partie
de données c'est très dangereux
moi ce qui me frappe c'est à quel point
personne ne parle des conséquences d'une
reconnaissance au québec exercice
systémique
tout le monde y font le choix des rôles
phares fonds non les autochtones et
autres en plus mais personne ne parle
des conséquences
il va avoir des conséquences c'est un
concept qui nous vient des états unis le
racisme systémique on importe en fait
une dynamique américaines qui vont
radicaliser les groupes là dessus c'est
un concept aussi qu'un pris racine au
canada anglais avec le multiculturalisme
biologique est adoptée en partie pour me
fais québec à sa place si on adopte le
concept de race est cité avec des
conséquences très simple il valoir foule
au portillon
parce que là il ya des groupes qui vont
demander des indemnités dès la
repentance ils m'ont demandé des quotas
attendez vous à ce que la loi sans la
politique linguistique soit contestée on
attendait beaucoup de gens qu'il en est
traité de façon égalitaire que je veux
dire c'est condé le québec on a des
richesses linguistiques ces jo
révélateur que des gens qui dira si ce
n'est qu'ils ont testé la loi sur la
laïcité
conséquence ça personne n'en parle des
conséquences vous en parlait hier josé
oui bon ben écoutez je pense que
christian vient tout de même de dire là
j'avais au canada et le québec jusqu'à
nouvel ordre fait partie du canada elior
racisme systémique envers les
autochtones principalement à cause mais
pas exclusivement de la loi fédérale sur
les haies qui date de 1976 et qui est
encore appliquée aujourd'hui et qui est
de l'apartheid économique social en
justice en santé et c'est bon cela étant
dit monsieur legault ne reculera pas ça
c'est très classe g on voit rarement un
premier ministre dire aussi clairement
le fond de sa pensée que cela et je
pense que de s'entêter à essayer de
vouloir lui faire dire le mot qui
commence par la lettre s ça ne donne
absolument
là où il a bougé parce que c'est sur la
nomination de nouveaux ministres aux
affaires autochtones
bon alors très rapidement suite à la
mort vraiment horrible de joris est
chanoine à l'hôpital de joliette une
anomie ian lafrenière
moi je suis d'avis que c'est une bonne
nomination je pense que c'est un bon
signe évidemment là aussi les attentes
sont énormes mais je pense qu'il
faudrait pas sous-estimer monsieur la
fronière dans sa capacité d'établir des
bons contacts avec les premières nations
mais sur disons l'explication que donne
monsieur legault qui a un groupe de
québécois qui pensent qu'il ya un air
bien un autre groupe de québécois qui
pensent qu'elle n'est pas le problème
avec ça et encore une fois je déborde
juste pour pour l'amour du débat parce
qu'il changera pas d'idée mais c'est que
le groupe qui pense que il ya du racisme
systémique si d'habitude déjà qu'ils
font partie des groupes qui en sont
victimes
un bon alors c'est mais c'est ce que je
voulais dire tout à l'heure une façon et
ouais ouais
monsieur est juste pour terminer l'année
mais monsieur legault monsieur legault a
promis des gestes a promis de l'action
et tito jackie et un homme pragmatique
un homme d'action et c'était ce qui sera
jugé bon très bien michel c
effectivement ça commence à tourner en
rond
mais le démon doit avancer sur les faits
et sur les actions qui sont aux prises
parce que le reste je pense qu'on
compris qu'on change les gens changeront
pas d'idées je compris quand on peut en
débattre ici aussi la cua quand est ce
que vos collègues jose mais alizé
il ya des gens qui changent dit kristin
zippel du racisme systémique contre des
autochtones il disait procès ya trois
semaines à leurs droits et déjà sur le
goût fonctionne toujours en disant
progressistes eric un système de raciste
si possible ces personnes vont assister
les quelque chose de très précis noyer
le poisson malfrats pro changé d'idée la
chose importante c'est qu'au moins
envers les autochtones parce que le
rapport vieille à toute sorte de
distance qu'ils ont adopté le québec de
façon générale au problème avec la façon
dont il traite ses autochtones et madame
et shaone emma est morte dans un hôpital
de juridiction provinciale avec des
haies et en se faisant insulter par des
gens qui étaient des fonctionnaires
provinciaux sont on peut pas le nier et
de ça je vais passer je vous entends sur
l'autre sujet
on va reparler de l'eau enfin entendre
monsieur trudeau monsieur legault sur
les normes nationales dans les sièges à
celle du en écoutant
je pense que tous les canadiens veulent
savoir que lara leurs parents leurs
grands parents et nos aînés sont
protégés sont bien appuyé à travers le
pays
c'est une conversation évidemment à voir
avec les premiers ministres des
provinces mais je pense que on ne
devrait pas voir des aînés mieux
protégés ou moins bien protégé dans une
région du pays que de l'autre jeu
certainement en parler avec avec les
provinces
moi je pense que monsieur trudeau joue
avec le feu parce que toutes les
provinces ont demandé d'avoir transfert
sans condition pour augmenter les
transferts en santé aux provinces je
pense pas que le gouvernement fédéral
devrait s'impliquer dans la gestion des
ch celle des monsieur trudeau fait une
erreur de proposer des mesures
centralisatrice je pense qu'il ya un
consensus en trop dans les provinces
comme le québec l'ontario pour avoir
plus d'autonomie sur le choix des moyens
pour atteindre nos objectifs en
particulier dans un domaine de
compétence comme la santé qui est
clairement un domaine de compétence
provinciale 20 secondes chacun de
chelsea au jus ne gère pas un seul c'est
le deal serait bien malvenu de déposer
des normes nationales
cela dit ça ça conséquence directe de
l'armée des ch et celle dé s'adonner une
poignée ouvertement pour fédéral de
faire ce qui fait souvent c'est à dire
vouloir rentrer dans des juridictions
qui ont pris six ans il faut c'est dans
l'action generali est une compétition
entre les deux niveaux de gouvernement
et quand j'ai un niveau du gouvernement
qui était pas fonctionnels ces
juridictions pourquoi s'étonner que
l'autre niveau c'est d'intervenir ce
sont tous cassés les libéraux de m josé
la même conclusion
ben collusion collision frontale entre
legault et trudeau là dessus ça c'est
très très claire entre autres choses et
je pense que monsieur legault va
continuer à marteler sa demande si vous
voulez que les choses s'améliorent
augmenté de financement et rendez le
récurrent merci beaucoup pour votre
discipline désolé de vous avoir précieux
pendant va se reparler de tout ça merci
au revoir à bientôt mesdames et
messieurs on se retrouve après tout la
pause